yeah so if you didn't watch the ncaa
championship it was kansas and unc uh
unc was up big at the half and then
kansas came back at one a lot of reasons
you could say unc booit but um one of
their star players got hurt in the game
and uh armando
beckett beckot that code i don't know
how you say his last name but uh say it
again armando bakkot say one more time
armando beckett oh that's fine no it's
british it did pronounce the british in
it
can you scroll up please
all right
let's establish two things here
one
carolina wins if armando bucket doesn't
go down
two freedom
all right let's this is the clip they
said the floor moves so if you watch the
clip you'll watch his right foot now
so rose's ankle looks like yeah so
here's my question to you guys do you
think the ankle is rolled because of the
floor
i do
i think if the floor moves as you're
trying to plant on it how are you stable
on that just it's just moving out of the
way how do you roll your ankle you step
into a lower surface you know i mean
like you're moving sideways and like you
step into a pothole
and that's what that is that's a pothole
yeah i i i don't know i've rolled my
angles a bunch like playing ball
that ankle roll right there comes from
him rolling his ankle a bunch
like it's just a weak tendon or
something i think and i think what
happened is he put he had a lot of force
going in one direction tried to plant
maybe the floor moving gave that little
i do yeah i mean once you roll your
ankle once it just rolls way more easily
it's a crazy thing but
it it seems like if you're trying to
plant especially when you're just like
one small part of your body like the
toes or whatever yeah and then the whole
floor moves your whole body's gonna move
in accordance with the floor shifting i
i i think
and that's where you're gonna you're
planted and then all of a sudden yeah
it's the same way like the corner of a
rug moves yeah and you step on it you
slip it's kind of like that yeah no i
i'm with you i just feel like
even if that floor doesn't move there's
a good chance that he rolls his ankle
because there's a lot of guys in the nba
you see roll their ankle and it's not
because the floor is moving and i also
think that the floor moves a lot more
than we assume you think so yeah like
there's a picture of zion dunking
recently the entire floor caves in when
he goes to jump did you see the one
where i i know that's in an arena this
was in a and this was put up there in a
stadium for this event so yeah now they
do put up the floor in sections yeah
they put up these little like rectangles
of floor and so people go ah they didn't
put it in right and it's like dude like
the the the old garden in boston yeah
you heard that you have like dead spots
and all that [ __ ] yeah but this is also
30 years later or whatever 100
i just think it's very convenient to be
like this is the reason why did he roll
his ankle earlier as well oh is that
true yeah well if you rolled it earlier
as well then then that's exactly what i
said something a knee injury or
something like he was playing with like
a bad knee or something like that yeah i
think i think he tore his meniscus and
then came back in the like came back for
the next game like went crazy how many
points did he score in the in that game
he tore his meniscus and then did 15
points 15 rebounds i think or something
went off and then was like going up for
like this final drive and then
boom
yeah it's still on now again i actually
didn't get to watch the game but uh it's
on unc for blowing a 15 point lead or
whatever at the half that's on you in
college it happens all the time because
they're not as good as pros but it's
still you take the blame for that loss
but if you're that player
aren't you pissed yeah 100 i mean could
you sue theoretically i wonder like
the you might be able to sue for damages
in terms of like physical damages yeah
um and how it could affect you
yeah yeah like in terms like you're in
walmart you slip and fall because
something's wet you can sue
or they might sign some crazy nda which
says like if you're injured while
playing yeah this is something that
happens as part of the game what happens
if shaq got injured when he pulled down
the hoop
i guarantee they all sign something that
goes that removes all liability from the
vendor like a waiver yeah like if you
went to snowboarding you know when you
get this the lifting now what if you
slip and it's because old boy didn't
wipe down the court
you know what i mean like because then
it's like you have someone that actually
has to drive there's negligence yeah
yeah but it's like sweat is constantly
dropping yeah it's i think it's part of
the game
the moment he passes like if i was the
ncaa wouldn't you make everybody sign
yeah it's just tougher you feel more bad
for them because pros get paid and they
just now started to be able to get paid
in his last year but now he can get like
an ace bandage deal he can get like
some sort of sponsorship 100 yeah and
just for facts he got injured on the
meniscus he rolled his ankle twice this
is on
literally what i said is it that angle
was ready to go final minutes you
planted hard yeah yeah that's also did
you see the arena that they played in no
i'm trying to find an actual picture not
an arena it's a stadium they played in a
stadium yeah they do that in uh
syracuse
yeah they well they did it for the
all-star game in dallas they played at
the cowboys stadium because you just a
basketball arena typically can't
accommodate that size of people yeah a
football stadium can so
the craziest game i've ever seen
the aircraft carrier oh that's so fire
so cool what is that like they set up a
it's a point oh i thought it was in san
diego no i forgot it's like a military
school they played right oh is that like
the olympic school they do one every
year where they play the army navy game
or something like that on an aircraft
carrier
what's that i thought i thought maybe
the olympic team did training there or
some [ __ ] but [ __ ] they might have but
like they set up an actual
court on the aircraft carrier and like
instead look look look yeah
so they're outside
oh that's fine isn't that cool i've
never seen that before that's fire yeah
now it probably throws you off shooting
because you know how when you shoot with
nothing in your background your depth
perception is all off yeah so but i i
just think this is a street ball at that
point yeah they're just hooping yeah
that's something that'd be fire the nba
you know how the nhl does the outdoor
the winter classic where they play
outdoors oh yeah yeah nba got to do that
right you need something you need
something so also when we were at radio
city they they played a wnba game in
radio city really they set the stage is
big enough where they could set up the
whole full court and then people just
watched it from one side wow that's
pretty sick that's interesting right
yeah but i like that idea like go away
look at all the empty seats
i know it's half full but
it's still probably a little too much
still yeah yeah six thousand
six thousand that's crazy but yeah there
is one about college sports like seeing
college players play at the very end
like i don't know i was trying to talk
to derek poston about this but like you
see them like they don't this is their
only shot
you know i mean like nba doesn't carry
the same stakes matter of fact in the
nba it's like i can't get injured
yeah because i lose out so much money so
let me hold off a little bit yeah
exactly but these guys are grinding
they're like i might not make it to
league this is my last chance
like i'm a senior i want to win this is
it like those college basketball tiers
like hit different than any other yeah
that's true